hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
ryan right today I'm gonna be covering
the news for the third week of jun 2015
angelina jolie is set to return for
Maleficent to maybe this time around she
might actually play someone evil I might
even have to call her malefic unto
drastic world has dominated the box
office for two straight weeks now if you
didn't see this coming then you probably
wouldn't see the indominus rex coming
you idiot if you laugh at that joke
you're also an idiot Forest Whitaker is
set to be one of the main cast members
of Star Wars road 1 details have yet to
be released of the character but
something tells me his character will
feature a lazy eye Michael Myers is set
to return in Halloween returns the
script has been written by two people
who have worked a lot on the saw
franchise this is good news because
these people clearly know how to keep a
franchise feeling fresh Jack Huston I
believe is the 47th actor now so I have
dropped out of the lead role in the crow
in the film Ava fly over 2x DX
productions if you haven't heard of sdx
it's not a transmittable disease Eli
Roth isn't talks to direct neg the story
is essentially about a Megalodon which
case you guys don't know was a
prehistoric shark that was over 50 feet
I can only imagine what spill berga
saying right now we're gonna need a
bigger boat
rumor has it Indiana Jones will come out
in 2018 this time around Harrison Ford
will not return but it will focus
primarily on the beloved Shia LaBeouf
character I'm just [ __ ] with you know
I could take Shia LaBeouf seriously
anymore a possible agreement between
sony and Marvel regarding spider-man may
have been linked the agreement states
that Peter Parker must be Caucasian and
heterosexual two things to which I am
NOT but I'm still going to wait in line
to audition anyway guys thanks for
tuning in if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine and you can catch my
videos on Latino Review com which is
actually sort of run by white people
it's a weird thing